a political rally in Guatemala City
supporters of Bernardo arebalo candidate
from semia or the seed party are marking
the official close of his presidential
campaign ahead of the August 20th
national election
many here say they're eager for the
election to be over and with it a
campaign season that's been marred by
allegations of election interference and
fraud
definitively we want the best results we
want the process to be transparent we
feel uncertainty about what's coming but
we hope democracy will prevail
[Music]
is seen by many as the biggest surprise
in recent electoral memory his victory
in the initial round of voting shook up
the political landscape he's now leading
in the polls ahead of the national
election
but Sandra Torres a former first lady of
Guatemala representing the conservative
National Unity of Hope party or une is
also a strong Contender and seen by many
as the more experienced candidate
according to polling data the issues
Guatemalans care most about are the ones
that affect the livelihoods of everyday
citizens like a struggling economy and
worsening crime
one of the biggest issues on the minds
of Guatemalan voters is deep-rooted
corruption which many people here say
has eroded the confidence they have in
their political leaders
it's this Collective sense of mistrust
experts say which could determine the
outcome of Sunday's vote
a fundamental achievement would be to
capitalize on the feeling of discontent
the feeling of weariness that exists
among a portion of the population to
reclaim those basic elements of
democracy this sentiment has been
building up over the past decade yet
there hasn't been a political force that
has managed to unify and translate that
collection of Expressions into votes
both candidates have promised to address
corruption while Torres emphasizes
transparency and accountability Arevalo
has proposed measures to disqualify
corrupt individuals from public office
as the runoff election approaches the
people of Guatemala are poised to cast
their votes in what's seen as a critical
moment for the nation's future
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Guatemala City